it is and now a little more about the
story we brought you at the top of the
hour from back under the sea take a look
at the giant fossil of a sea reptile
recently found in the middle of england
in near pristine condition this skeleton
is thought to be about 180 million years
old and as charlie dagida shows us it
could help us understand our own future
it didn't look like much at first a
conservation team thought they found
maybe an old broken pipe sticking out of
the mud after draining a reservoir
but what joe davis stumbled upon has
been described as one of the greatest
fossil finds in the history of british
paleontology a lot of people spend their
careers looking for something like this
my kids have now
named me jurassic what joe rasic
discovered lurking beneath the mud were
the remains of a monumental 180 million
year old beast a beast paleontologist
dean lomax has spent a career hunting
down
not only is this the the largest
ichthyosaur skeleton ever found in
britain but it's also the the largest
complete skeleton of any prehistoric
reptile found here in the in the uk as
well known as the sea dragon the air
breathing apex predator ruled the seas
like a huge bloodthirsty dolphin
raising the monster from the deep was a
complex and delicate operation that
meant covering it up in plaster and
transporting it to a warehouse
and here it is and it is actually the
length of a double decker bus around 33
feet long the skull alone is more than
six feet long and weighs nearly a ton
paleontologist nigel larkin helped lead
the excavation what was going through
your mind as you started to uncover
these segments and thought wow we
thought is it going to be 10 complete 20
hey it could be 50 complete so as we're
digging away it's just getting bigger
and bigger we couldn't believe it
jackpot yeah fantastic a jackpot that
goes far beyond what will eventually be
a pretty impressive museum piece
what was the reason they died out what
can we learn
we can learn a lot from fossils
generally we can only predict future
climate change by understanding past
climate change and how animals like this
adapted to climate change or fail to
adapt unlocking the secrets of the deep
and the deep past may help us learn to
adapt to our own future
charlie dagetta shrewsbury england
it's extraordinary remarkable creatures